so we got the beach and you know if you
told me the synopsis of this or if like
I don't know if I was like a director or
producer some like that and somebody
came out to me is that okay here's the
synopsis of this episode I say are you
nuts
but it's the toughest thing I've ever
heard but is surprisingly pretty
effective um it's an episode where our
villains go to a beach house and they go
to a beach party and they sit around
sore I have a breakfast club type
discussion near the end around the fire
and it's it's basically them just being
teenagers and it's needed it's really
needed and it's very nice to see and
it's nice to see them still stay in
character but also interact with other
kids their age not knowing who they are
and I like how Zola is fascinated that
they don't know who they are and they
want and she probably more than anything
just wants to see what she can get out
of it or she can have more power over by
doing this or we should get torment more
and feel better by doing it by an egg
that stuff's always fun but even though
we get a little bit of her humanity in
there and how she's obviously sort of
once a while dipping into her real
feelings but not much um and it worth
bizarrely kind of well at times I'm like
this is like you know in an Ethel a
cello movie or something it's like a
beach movie but they they really address
what it means to be this age and with
your family and to have jealousy to have
anger to have confusion they captured
they captured it well and be well the
problems I had with The Breakfast Club
even though I do like it technically is
that I felt they've really captured the
emotions and the feelings of the
dilemmas and the confusion all that
stuff of being a teenager but the one
thing they didn't catch is that they
don't talk about it they don't discuss
it with other teenagers
so I always thought that was kind of a
problem with the movie but here these
four are so strange already and they
have been uh shielded from so much of
the rest of the world that you can buy
it you can see them talking about and at
times it's it's a touch rushed but it
still comes out well you still get the
idea what they're talking about and the
emotions and stuff and some of is kind
of obvious - like Zuko
not knowing who he's angry and you know
you just wait for him to save myself
myself of course he eventually says it
but I liked learning about ty Lee I
liked learning about me I liked even
well I can say with Azula just seeing
that little bit of humanity that shine
through just for a moment and and even
then she wants to be a sibling she wants
to be a friend at time that she's trying
to it's almost like she's trying to
figure out the human-animal what it
means to be human the last thing I'll
say before I sign off here is it's um I
don't usually talk about but the sound
design and the sound direction on this
was really good and I'm thinking
specifically when the guy with the eye
on his head I don't know his name but he
can make stuff explode with it he comes
out and this thing shoots from his head
and they do that wonderful trick where
they have this loud sound and then like
a half second of silence before the big
explosion and that's surprisingly very
effective and on top of that the sound
of it coming out it's not like a giant
shoe or anything really loud it's this
very piece very quiet little snaps
almost sort of like small fireworks and
it's really effective you just hear it
coming and you sort of I don't know what
it is but you just saw you shift a
little bit because you kind of feel like
it's almost whizzing by you it remind me
a lot of the opening of Saving Private
Ryan again great sound design on that
when the you don't hear the bang bang
bang from the guns you hear the
whooshing by of the bullets and you just
hear them hitting things you hear the
pings hitting off the metal and that's
enough it feels like it's closer when
you can hear something just the
slightest thing close
to your ears Kassar like we hear a bug
buzzing you go I like that even though
it's not something big and massive it's
really close and something about that
illusion really helps that those small
sounds can actually somehow seem closer
and more threatening and I thought that
was a very very clever choice uh in the
sound design of that so I get a good
sound design editing directing all that
stuff uh and yeah just an episode I
would not think would have worked but
was surprisingly pretty decent and I
just I love seeing the characters
interact against on my favorite
characters here are the villains again I
love the villains in this show and I
just love seeing them interact I love
seeing them I love seeing them be family
and friends and you get the feeling how
they acted when they were family and
friends when they were younger but also
how much time has changed I love it when
Zuko went to the old house he looked at
the picture and he realizes how
different times so you know how those
were different times and he misses it
but he can't live in it and he burns the
picture in the fire and it's a good good
moments and he seemed like very strong
real sore a teenage archetypes too that
you see quite often and they give them
reasons why they are that way so a
surprisingly strong episode and worked
out really really nicely so yeah that's
about it see you in the next one